down to the war in Ukraine Russia says
it is pulling out of a key region in the
South the military says it's withdrawing
from her son a move seen as a huge
defeat for President Vladimir Putin
Putin annexed the region in September
making it part of Russia Chris livsei is
in Ukraine with the latest on the
withdrawal and the response from Kiev
in a war riddled with Russian failures
the Kremlin could point to Harrison one
crowning achievement until now the
Russian defense Ministry is now
announcing a withdrawal from the region
starting with the West Bank of the
Nipper River for now the city remains
under Russian occupation it's the only
Regional capital Russia has held since
the start of the war backed by billions
in U.S and international Aid Ukraine is
now moving in but with Extreme Caution
it could after all be a trap as
Ukrainian president zielinski suggests
the enemy he says does not hand out
gifts
but the enemy has suffered astonishing
losses thanks in large part to a steady
flow of American Firepower it's evidence
of the fact that they have some real
problems Russian the Russian military
only recently Putin held a Victory
celebration in Moscow to announce his
illegal annexation of four Ukrainian
regions including her song they are
becoming our citizens forever he said
but for Ukraine's advancing Army and the
people living under occupation forever
may not last much longer
and the timing is very interesting one
Russian TV presenter said this
withdrawal is happening after the U.S
midterm elections because they didn't
want to give a boost to Joe Biden and
his allies Vlad
Chris lipsay in Ukraine Chris thank you
very much stay safe